This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Since 2002, the Beverly Willis Architecture Foundation has worked to remedy the egregious omission of women from the popular history of architecture. They accomplished this through original research, creating websites, making short films, and now producing audio documentaries. Their podcast, New Angle Voice, highlights the lives and careers of the pioneering women of American architecture, and we're delighted to present this story about one of the driving What is your name, please?
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马斯。自2002年以来，贝弗利·威利斯建筑基金会一直致力于弥补大众建筑史中严重漏掉女性的过失。他们通过原创研究、建立网站、制作短片以及现在的音频纪录片来实现这一点。他们的播客节目《新角度之声》聚焦于美国建筑界先驱女性的生活与职业生涯，我们很高兴为您呈现这个关于其中一位推动者的故事。请问你叫什么名字？
My name is Natalie DeBlois. What is your name, please? My name is Natalie DeBlois. What is your name, please? My name is Natalie De or DuPloy. Two of these people are imposter, only one of them is real, and is the only one sworn to tell the truth.
我叫娜塔莉·德布瓦。请问你叫什么名字？我叫娜塔莉·德布瓦。请问你叫什么名字？我叫娜塔莉·德或杜普洛伊。这些人中有两个是冒名顶替者，只有一个人是真的，而且她是唯一发誓要说实话的人。
And here is our host, Bud Coyer. Welcome to New Angle Voice. I'm your host, Cynthia Crackauer. On today's episode, Natalie DeBloy, who we just heard in a clip from her 1958 appearance on the popular quiz show to tell the truth. Who was Natalie DeBloy? She was an architect of great accomplishment, but she came into the field at a time when few women were in the profession. Men were returning from war, the economy was booming, but women?
我们的主持人布德·科耶尔登场。欢迎来到《新角度之声》。我是主持人辛西娅·克拉克劳尔。在今天的节目中，娜塔莉·德布瓦刚刚在1958年热门问答节目《说出真相》的片段中亮相。娜塔莉·德布瓦是谁？她是一位成就斐然的建筑师，但她进入这一领域时，行当里几乎没有女性。男人从战场归来，经济蓬勃发展，但女性呢？
They were often relegated to jobs within the pink collar sector and the secretarial pool. This is the world that Natalie entered. During her early days at Skidmore Owings in Merrill, she had four children and managed to retain her job. This might seem like an obvious fact by today's standards, but we have to remember, job security for new mothers couldn't be assumed for women during this time.
她们往往被归入粉领阶层和秘书池的工作。这就是娜塔莉进入的世界。在SOM建筑事务所（Skidmore, Owings & Merrill）的早期，她生了四个孩子，并设法保住了工作。以今天的标准来看，这似乎是一个显而易见的事实，但我们必须记住，当时女性无法理所当然地享有新母亲的职业保障。
It's thought that Natalie was the first woman at the firm to be given maternity leave, but it was not an easy road, and as her son reflected, she was no housewife. While she was helping build the modern skyline of Park Avenue, the life she returned home to at night was not as glamorous. It was hard, and she often struggled, proving once again that it's hard for women to balance a successful professional career and raise a family. It was then and still is today. As an architect, Natalie loves systems, understanding how building components work together. For her, it wasn't just pretty buildings. She challenged the codes and questioned existing technologies.
人们认为娜塔莉是该事务所第一位获得产假的女性，但这并非一条平坦的道路，正如她儿子所反思的那样，她绝不是什么家庭主妇。当她协助建造公园大道的现代天际线时，她晚上回到家中的生活却并没有那么光鲜亮丽。生活很艰难，她常常苦苦挣扎，这再次证明了女性要在保持成功的职业生涯和抚养家庭之间取得平衡是多么不易。过去如此，今天依然如此。作为一名建筑师，娜塔莉热爱系统，热衷于理解建筑构件是如何协同工作的。对她而言，建筑不只是漂亮的外表。她挑战规范，质疑现有技术。
She handled design challenges with an elegant simplicity that belive their complexity. And like the buildings she designed, there was a certain complexity to Natalie herself. She was a woman of resilient beauty, inspiring, yet distant. Ahead of her time, often overshadowed by her male counterparts, we hope to shed light on her life's work and her legacy. In this episode, Natalie DeBloy, to tell the truth. All right, panel, will you follow along with your copies of this, Affidavit?
她以一种优雅的简练来处理设计挑战，掩盖了其复杂性。正如她设计的建筑一样，娜塔莉本人也有着某种复杂性。她是一位兼具坚韧之美、既鼓舞人心又略带疏离感的女性。她超前于时代，却常常被男性同行所掩盖，我们希望借此机会阐明她一生的工作与遗产。在本期节目中，娜塔莉·德布瓦，请说出真相。好了，各位评委，请对照你们手中的这份宣誓书吗？
I, Natalie DeBloy, am a registered architect and member of the New York chapter of the American Institute of Architects. I am employed as a senior designer and an associate in the architectural firm of Skidmore, Owings and Merrill, and have worked as a senior designer on buildings both here and abroad, including two American consulates in Germany and one of the Hilton chain of international hotels. I am currently working as a senior designer on the new Block Square 50 Story High Union
我，娜塔莉·德布瓦，是一名注册建筑师，也是美国建筑师协会纽约分会的会员。我受雇于斯基德莫尔、奥因斯与梅里尔建筑事务所（Skidmore, Owings & Merrill），担任高级设计师和副合伙人，曾在本土和海外的建筑项目中担任高级设计师，包括德国的两座美国领事馆和希尔顿国际连锁酒店之一。我目前正在担任新建的50层高的方块广场联合碳化合物大楼的高级设计师，该大楼目前正在纽约施工。我已婚，是四个孩子的母亲，签名娜塔莉·德布瓦。今天是2002年3月12日。我和娜塔莉·杜布瓦在她位于康涅狄格州西哈特福德的家中。我们在此聚首，旨在用娜塔莉自己的话记录她卓越的40多年职业生涯的亮点。是的，从头到尾40年。实际上，接近50年。好的。好的。
Carbide Building, now under construction in New York. I am married and the mother of four children, signed Natalie DeBloy. Today is March 12, 2002. And I'm with Natalie Dubois in her home in West Hartford, Connecticut. We are here together to document in Natalie's own words highlights of her remarkable 40 plus years career. Yeah, 40 from beginning to end. Actually, it's close to 50. Okay. Okay.
这段职业生涯的大部分时间都没有得到应有的认可。这份口述历史旨在阐明尚未公开的信息，填补历史记录中的空白，并澄清事实。娜塔莉·德布瓦是一位鲜为人知的建筑师，活跃于20世纪中期。她曾是SOM建筑事务所的高级设计师。她参与了许多建筑的设计，这些建筑确立了我们今天所认为的20世纪中期美国现代建筑的标志性形象。我是加布里埃尔·埃斯佩蒂。我是一名
Much of this career has passed without the recognition it was due. This oral history is intended to shed light on what is not yet public information. Fill gaps in the historical record and set the record straight. Natalie DeBloy is an under-known architect who practiced in the middle of the 20th century. She was a senior designer at Skidmore Owings and Merrill. She contributed to many of the buildings that established what we now think of as the iconic image of American modern architecture in the middle of the 20th century. I'm Gabrielle Esperty. I am an
建筑与城市历史学家。我是纽瓦克新泽西理工学院的建筑学教授，也是“美国建筑先驱女性”项目中娜塔莉·德布瓦简介的作者。你说过你在10岁或11岁时就知道自己想成为一名建筑师。我是怎么知道的？我喜欢建筑、房子和植物。我一直追溯到1939年。那所学校。
architectural and urban historian. I'm a professor of architecture at the New Jersey Institute of Technology in Newark and I am the author of the Natalie DeBloy profile in the pioneering women of American architecture project. You said that you knew you wanted to be an architect when you were 10 or 11 years old. How did I know? I liked buildings and houses and plants. I went up to 1939. The school.
这是一个新时代的曙光。我看到了现代建筑，这给我留下了深刻的印象。我父亲明确告诉我，建筑是一个极少有女性涉足的专业。他剪下报纸上的文章拿给我看这些东西。但这对我没有什么影响。我有其他事情要操心，要做出我不得不做出的决定。这对我是件难事，但我还是做出了决定。渐渐地，我对建筑界正在发生的事情有了更多了解。莫里斯·凯彻姆的办公室，他们做什么类型的工作？
It's the dawn of a new day. I saw modern buildings, and that impressed me enormously. My father made it clear to me that architecture was a professional, whether it was only very few women. He cut our articles and newspapers and showed me these things. But that had no effect on me. I had other things to worry about, making these decisions that I had to make. It was a difficult thing for me, but I made them. Little by little, I got to know more about what was going on in the architectural world. Morris Ketchum's office, what kind of work did they do?
莫里斯·凯彻姆做过两个引人注目的现代商店。它们是纽约市最早建造的现代建筑的一部分，我非常高兴能获得凯彻姆事务所的工作机会，因为他们是现代建筑师，这真的让我很高兴。这很重要。我大学一毕业就开始工作了，那是44年1月的冬天。我们算是一个亲密的群体。那是一家非常小的公司。三个年轻人，听说是几个男人。我们常聚在一起。我们在
Morris Ketchum had done two spectacular modern shops. They were some of the earliest modern architecture that was built in New York City, I was just so pleased that I was offered a job at Catchums because they were modern architects and that really pleased me. That was important. I started working right after college, that winter of January 44. We were sort of an intimate group. It was a very small firm. Three young people heard a couple of men. We'd hang out together. We'd socialized outside of the
办公室外也会社交。其中一个家伙经常带我去跳舞，听本尼·古德曼和汤米·多尔西的音乐，无论他们在哪里演出。到了某个时候，其中一个伙计迷恋上了娜塔莉，对她没有回应他的追求感到沮丧。他去找了事务所的合伙人，把这件事说了出来，并说：“我没法和她一起工作。她必须离开，因为她不接受我的追求。”凯彻姆先生叫我去他的办公室，并告诉我不得不离开。
office. One of the fellows used to take me out dancing to hear Benny Goodman and Tommy Dorsey and wherever they were playing. And at some point one of the guys was enamored with Natalie and upset that she was not acknowledging his advances. And he went to the partner of the firm and told him this and said, I can't work with her. She has to leave because she won't accept my advances. Mr. Ketchum asked me to come over to his office and he told me I would have to leave.
于是事务所的合伙人解雇了她。解雇了她。太惊人了。凯彻姆先生调和了此事。这确实是外界对待女性的第一场遭遇。他写了这封信给我，说由于他无法控制的情况，她不得不离开。他说，我会打电话给在九楼或十楼的路易·斯切德纳，看看他那里有没有适合我们的位置。
So the partner of the firm fired her. Fired her. Amazing. And Mr. Ketchum combined. This was really a first shop of what happened in the outside world with women. He wrote me this letter and said, do the circumstances beyond his control she has to leave. He said, I'll call up Louis Schedner who's down on the ninth or tenth floor. See if he has a place for us.
于是他拿起电话打给路易·斯切德纳，说他要派个人过去。他建立了那个联系，这就是她最终来到斯切德纳的原因。所以他们确实雇用了她。然后我想，即使在斯切德纳，也有关于她只是（你知道的）被排除在核心圈子之外的故事。你知道，那是一个纯爷们儿的俱乐部。我是奥黛丽·马特洛克，纽约奥黛丽·马特洛克建筑师事务所的负责人兼业主。她从没真正去想过这些。我想她满脑子都是工作。她只对工作感兴趣，所以她并不在乎晋升或赞誉。有些时候，男性合伙人和客户在开会，
So he picked up the phone and called up Louis Schedner and said he was going to send somebody down thing. He made that contact and that's how she ended up at Schedner. So they did hire her. And then I think even at Schedner there were stories that she told about just being, you know, not part of the club. You know, it was a boys club. I'm Audrey Matlock, principal and owner of Audrey Matlock Architect in New York. She never thought about it really. I think she thought about the work. She was only interested in the work, so she wasn't looking for advancement or accolades. There were instances where the male partners and clients were having a meeting
而她也在会场里，因为她掌握了所有的信息，真正干活的人正是她。然后到了吃午饭的时候，他们要去参加什么男士俱乐部之类的活动，路易·斯基德莫尔看着她说：“嘿，确保我们吃完午饭回来时你在两点前回到这里。”然后他们把她晾在一边走了，她说她当时只是（你知道的）去洗手间哭了一场，她把这些事情看得很重，因为她对待工作极其认真，把所有的心血都倾注在了其中，所以这种冷遇对她来说非常痛苦。我第一次见到娜塔莉是在80年代末我在SOM建筑事务所工作的时候。娜塔莉应邀前来做讲座。我事先得到提醒，我务必
and she was in the meeting because she had all the information because she was the one actually doing the work. And then when it was time for lunch, they were going to do some men's club or other and Louis Skidmore looks at her and says, hey, make sure you're back here at two when we're back from lunch and they walked out without her and she said She just you know went in the bathroom pride and she took these things very personally because she was so Serious about her work and she put everything she had into it and so these kinds of slides were very painful to her I first met Natalie when I was working at Skidmore, Owens and Merrill back in the late 80s. Natalie was invited to come and give a lecture. I had been alerted beforehand that I definitely had
要努力去认识她。在她演讲结束后，我从头到脚打量了一番，然后说：“哦，你是做室内设计的吗？”我当时简直，垂头丧气。心想：怎么能这么说呢？不，不，不，我是一名建筑师。不管怎样，我们聊了起来，一拍即合。这可以说是我们友谊的开始。作为一个比她年轻一些的人，但我也是一个在60年代进入职场的人，
to make an effort to get to know her. After her talk, I me head to toe and said, oh, are you in interiors? And I just about, I was crestfallen. And no, how can you say that? No, no, no, I'm an architect. Anyway, we struck up a conversation and hit it off. And that kind of started our friendship. Speaking as a person somewhat younger than she is, but as a person who entered the job market in the 60s,
那与她的经历不同，可能还要更糟糕。男人是老板，我们照吩咐行事。我们知道谁是老板，我们知道情况如何，我想她也是。但我们只能听从吩咐。我们知道谁是老板，我们知道情况如何，我想她也是。56年，我又怀了一个孩子，戈登告诉我：“如果你还没生下孩子，就别出现在那个开幕式上。”
which is different from her experience, it was probably worse. Men were the bosses and we did what we were told. We knew the boss was, we knew what the situation was, and I imagine she did too. but we were told. We knew the boss was, we knew what the situation was, and I imagine she did too. 56, I had another child, and Gordon told me, don't show up at that opening ceremony
他为什么这么说？你让男人们感到尴尬吗？我到了那里，简直惊艳全场。人们不知为何对怀孕的女性感到尴尬。有什么好尴尬的？我不知道。也许是想到你跟某人发生过性关系吧。男人们就是不大动脑筋。
if you haven't had your baby yet. Why did he say that? Are you an embarrassment to the men? I'm there, slay. People were somehow embarrassed by pregnant women. What's embarrassing? I don't know. Maybe the idea that, you had sex with somebody. Men just didn't think very hard.
她在事务所里拥有崇高的地位，因为她是高级设计师或他们所称的某个头衔。所以显然每个人都尊重她的能力，但这并不意味着他们想听她在会议上发言。我不知道他们是否想听。我不知道她是否畅所欲言。但这并不意味着他们会由衷地对这个女孩要说的话感兴趣。
She had an eminent position in the firm because she was a senior designer or whatever they called it. So clearly everybody respected her ability, but it didn't mean that they wanted to hear her speak at a meeting. I don't know whether they did. I don't know whether she spoke up. But it wouldn't have meant that they were deeply interested in hearing what this girl had to say.
在很长一段时间里，我们都被称为“女孩”，而且我确信，即使她已经50岁了，他们谈论她时依然会叫她女孩。这就是人们说话的方式。我是卡罗尔·金斯基。我是纽约大学的艺术与建筑史教授，我从1965年开始在那里教书。我写了一本关于戈登·邦沙夫特的书，他正是监督娜塔莉·德布瓦的人。SOM建筑事务所是由路易·斯基德莫尔和纳撒尼尔·奥因斯在两次世界大战之间创立的。二战后，他们接到了设计利华大厦（Leaver House）的委托。
And we were known as girls for a very long time, and I'm sure they spoke of her as a girl even if she was 50 years old. It was just the way people spoke. My name is Carol Kinsky. I'm a professor of art and architectural history at New York University, where I had been teaching since 1965. I wrote a book about Gordon Bunchaft, who was the person who was supervising Natalie Deploy. Skidmore Oins and Merrill was established between the two world wars by Louis Skidmore and Nathaniel Owings. After the Second World War, they got the commission to do Leaver House.
我认为这让SOM建筑事务所名声大噪。这些年轻的现代主义者，他们都读过勒·柯布西耶的书，所以他们渴望这种纯净、棱角分明的建筑，然后他们又关注了实际来到美国的密斯·凡·德罗。他们知道密斯在纽约的一些建筑落成之前就已经在芝加哥建造玻璃建筑了，他们不想让自己的建筑显得落后于时代，所以我们最终得到了这样的成果。
I think that put Skidmore Owings and Merrill on the map. These young modern Hutchhots, they all read Le Corbusier, and so they wanted these pristine, prismatic buildings, and then they looked at Mies van der Rohe who had actually come to the USA. They knew that Mies was building in glass in Chicago before some of these buildings went up in New York, and they didn't want to look as if their buildings were being left behind, so we get what we get.
这可以说是反两次世界大战期间的现代主义一代，他们勇往直前，更加激进等等，你可以说服企业高管他们需要一种新风格的建筑，然后其他人就会跟风。第一个当然是公园大道的利华大厦，这让每个人都感到震惊。我还记得那里原本是砖面建筑，低层带有石灰石。只剩下一两栋了，
It's sort of anti-the interwar generation of modernists, and charging forward where younger, where more progressive and so forth, and you can persuade corporate officials that they need a new style of architecture, and then other people jump on the bandwagon. The first one was, of course, Leaver House on Park Avenue, and it was a shock to everyone. I can remember the brick-faced buildings that were there with limestone on the lower levels. They were one or two left,
上面是一种看起来平平无奇的棕褐色砖块。它们是公寓酒店。它们是真正的酒店。它们是普通的那种公寓楼，也是办公楼，而且很无聊。突然之间，利华大厦出现了，它是绿色的，周围有大量的光线。哦天哪，那上面是什么，树？哦，每个人都看到了什么？利华大厦。人们甚至特地跑出去亲眼目睹它。我记得读过刘易斯·芒福德的文章，他曾为《纽约客》撰稿，他说出租车司机
and a kind of nothing-looking tan brick above. They were apartment hotels. They were real hotels. They were apartment houses of a normal real hotels, they were apartment houses of a normal kind and they were office buildings and they were boring. All of a sudden, lever house appeared green with a lot of light around it. Oh my goodness, what's up there, trees? Oh, what's everybody saw? Leaver house. People went out there literally to see it. I remember reading Lewis Mumford, he wrote for the New Yorker, and he said taxi drivers
会特意绕路让乘客去看这座令人惊叹的新建筑。所以，当联合碳化合物公司计划搬到公园大道时，他们也想要一栋玻璃建筑，这也就不足为奇了。然后百事可乐搬来时，然后投机性办公楼开发商搬到公园大道并获得地块时，他们也想要玻璃建筑，于是就有了我们今天看到的景象。娜塔莉对利华大厦、百事可乐大厦、联合碳化合物大楼等建筑的贡献，彻底改变了公园大道的面貌，这种改变是我们现在根本无法体会的。
would divert their customers to see this amazing new building. So it's not very surprising that when Union Carbide planned to move to Park Avenue, they too wanted a glass building. And then when Pepsi Cola moved, and then when speculative office promoters moved to Park Avenue and got sites, they also wanted glass buildings, so we got what we have now. Natalie's contribution to buildings like Leaver House, PepsiCo, Union Carbide, those changed the face of Park Avenue in a way that we simply don't understand it now.
当我们今天在公园大道上漫步时，我们已经无法感知它在多大程度上改变了我们对城市景观的想象。因为现在我们看到的是一座又一座、连绵不断的塔楼，而在战后初期，这里的景象截然不同。利华大厦确实给人们带来了启示。这也是为什么公园大道会成为所有这些电影的取景地。我曾看过一部名为《万物至尊》（The Best of Everything）的电影，它是20th Century Fox于1959年出品的影片。
When we walk up and down Park Avenue today, we don't have a sense of how much it changed our image of the urban landscape. Because now we see one tower after another, after another, and it looked very different, certainly immediately after the war. The Leaver House, it really was a revelation to people. It's why Park Avenue was featured in all of these movies. One that I've come across called the Best of Everything. It's a 20th century fox picture from 1959.
讲述了一群年轻的职场女性来到纽约闯荡的故事，其中一个主角最终在西格朗大厦找到了一份工作，而背景中总能看到利华大厦。事实上，我发现了一件以前没有意识到事情，辛迪·舍曼最著名的电影剧照系列之一中，她扮演的就是这部电影中的主角。事实上，我意识到，哦，那是辛迪·舍曼的照片，背景里就是利华大厦。回想娜塔莉在50和60年代的纽约所做的工作，作为一名女性参与设计这些如今标志性的企业办公大楼，这很有趣。
It's about a bunch of young career gals who come to New York to make their way, and one of the main characters ends up getting a job in the Seagron building, but the Lieber House is always in the background. In fact, one thing I discovered that I hadn't realized is that one of Cindy Sherman's most famous photographs of her movie still series, she is playing the main character in this movie. In fact, I realize, oh, that's the Cindy Sherman picture and the lever houses in the background. It is interesting to think about Natalie's work in New York in the 50s and 60s, participating in the design of these now iconic corporate office towers as a
很显然，女性并不多。在所有这些建筑里，她们只待在秘书池里。她们担任着这些行政职位，而不是像人们常说的那样占据转角办公室。回想娜塔莉自己并没有占据SOM的转角办公室，这很有趣。娜塔莉作为一个女性在那个特殊时刻扮演的角色具有某种讽刺意味，但同样重要的是，这也是一个女性开始更加明确地宣称她们对建成环境产生影响的时刻。
woman. Obviously, there weren't a lot of women. In all of those buildings, they were just in the Secretarial Pool. They were in these administrative positions, not occupying the corner office as it were. And it's interesting to think about Natalie herself, not occupying the corner office of SOM. There is a certain irony in Natalie's role as a woman at that moment, but it's also important to note, it is a moment when women were beginning to more explicitly assert an influence on the built environment.
如果你想到娜塔莉在设计这些建筑的同个时刻，简·雅各布斯正在挑战现代主义城市规划的观念，阿达·路易斯·赫克斯塔布尔作为《纽约时报》的第一位建筑评论家，正在将关于建筑的讨论引入大众对话。把她置于那个时代真的很有趣。你做过的事情之一就是百事可乐大楼。哦是的，那是一座美丽的小建筑。文献中几乎无一例外地称它为“优雅的珠宝盒”。百事可乐雇用了我们。
If you think that Natalie is working on these buildings, that exactly the same moment, that Jane Jacobs is challenging notions of modernist urban planning, that Ada Louise Huxstable is the New York Times first architecture critic and who is bringing conversations about architecture into a popular conversation. It's really kind of interesting to put her in that moment. One of the things you did do was PepsiCo. Oh yeah, that was beautiful little built. It has been called in the literature, almost without exception, as an elegant jewel box. Pepsicara hired us.
鲍勃·卡特勒是行政主管。他是斯蒂尔先生的朋友，斯蒂尔先生是百事可乐的总裁，娶了琼·克劳福德。二战后不断变化的经济动态，企业办公大楼建设的繁荣。值得注意的是，任何特定企业的总部前台与行政部门与制造基地的这种分离，在此之前就已经完成了。
Bob Cutler was the administrative officer. He was a friend of Mr. Steele, who was the president of Pepsicara, who was married to Joan Crawford. The dynamics of the changing economy after World War II, the boom in the construction of corporate office towers. It's important to note that that kind of separation of the front office and the administrative arm of any given corporation had already been separated from the manufacturing sites.
这在二战前就已经发生了，但在战后时期无疑仍在加速推进。因此，你会看到像百事可乐、联合碳化合物、利华兄弟这样的企业，它们明白自己需要在国家的商业中心拥有某种行政企业的存在感。所以，是的，这些企业大楼确实成为了美国经济转型的象征。到1961年，让我们花一分钟盘点一下。你有四个年幼的孩子，在SOM纽约事务所拥有职业生涯，但你搬到了芝加哥。嗯，我也和丈夫离婚了。
That had already happened before World War II, but it certainly continues a pace in the post-war period. And so you have buildings like PepsiCo, Union Carbide, Leaver Brothers, who understand that they need a kind of administrative corporate presence in the commercial heart of the country. And so yeah, those corporate towers really do become a symbol of the transformation of the American economy. By 1961, let's take stock for just a minute. You had four young children and a career at SOM, New York, but you moved to Chicago. Well, I divorced my husband too.
哦，我的笔记里没有这个，不过好吧，那对你来说确实是具有里程碑意义的一年。是的。我一直在想这一切如何平衡，你的家庭和你的职业。我并没有真正保持平衡。我和丈夫之间不断出现问题，因为你太全身心投入工作了。不，因为他是个酒鬼，这很艰难。我们的家庭历史，很难启齿。她显然工作极其努力，因此，你知道的，她绝不是什么家庭主妇。我是罗伯特·德布瓦，我是娜塔莉·德布瓦的儿子。娜塔莉，她
Oh, that's not in my notes, but okay, that really was a banner year for you. Yeah. I've been thinking all of this in balance, your family and your profession. I didn't really keep it in balance. I had continual problems with my husband because you were so devoted to your practice. No, because he was an alcoholic and it was difficult. Our family history, it's difficult to talk about. She obviously worked incredibly hard and as a result you know she was no housewife. My name is Robert DeBloy I'm the son of Natalie DeBloy. Natalie she
跟我们交流不多。她回家后从不谈论工作，我们会吃晚饭，听收音机。我父母都不会跟我们多说什么。我爸爸，通常他回家时，我的意思是，他是个酒鬼。发生过几次非常激烈、创伤性的事件。
did not communicate a lot with us. She never talked about her work when she came home we would have dinner, would listen to the radio. Neither of my parents would talk to us much. My dad, usually when he came home, I mean, he was an alcoholic. There were a couple of very intense, traumatic incidents that happened.
那大约是在他们离婚的时候。在那之后，我所知道的下一件事就是我们搬出了房子。我的前夫雷马里住在芝加哥，他的新妻子想帮忙照顾孩子们。我去芝加哥探访，顺便去了斯基德莫尔、奥因斯与梅里尔建筑事务所的办公室，布鲁斯·格雷厄姆说他希望我能去那里工作，并说：“我们会让你担任副合伙人。”所以我告诉了戈登，戈登告诉我：
It was about the time of their divorce. And after that, the next thing I know, we had moved out of the house. My former husband, Remarie was living in Chicago, and his new wife wanted to help take care of the children. I visited in Chicago, and I stopped in the office of Skidmoreng's Mall and Bruce Graham said he'd like me to come work there and he said, we'll make you a associate partner. So I told Gordon, Gordon told me,
“如果你想去芝加哥分所，那没问题。但我想告诉你三件事。第一点是，我想告诉你三件事。第一点是，你永远无法与布鲁斯·格雷厄姆相处融洽。第二点，你永远不会被升为合伙人。”基本上，他的理论是永远不会有任何女性合伙人。第三点，他说：“如果你愿意，你随时可以回到纽约。”所以我决定去。
if you want to go to the Chicago office, that's fine. But I want to tell you three things. One is, I want to tell you three things. One is, you'll never get along with Bruce Graham. Two, you'll never be made a partner. Basically, his theory was there's not going to be any women partners ever. And thirdly, he said, you can always come back to New York if you'd like to. So I decided to go.
这就是为什么我收拾好孩子们，把家庭搬到芝加哥，开始为布鲁斯工作。我经手的第一座项目是公平大厦。我们还为一个银行项目工作，即圣约瑟夫山谷银行。玛格丽特·麦柯里负责室内设计。我和玛格丽特合作过好几个项目。那非常有趣。有些女性走在了时代的前面，娜塔莉绝对是其中之一。
So that's why I picked up my kids, moved my family to Chicago, and I started working for Bruce. The first project I worked on was the Equitable Building. We also worked on a bank building for St. Joseph Valley Bank. It's Margaret McCurry was in charge of the interiors. I worked with Margaret on several jobs. That was a lot of fun. Some women were ahead of their times, and Natalie would certainly be one of them.
抚养四个男孩还要应付SOM的工作要求，这太惊人了。我的意思是，当有项目在进行时，我们不到半夜是绝对不会离开那里的。那是自然而然的。你就在那里。我是玛格丽特·麦柯里。我是泰格曼·麦柯里建筑师事务所的合伙人。
Amazing to raise four boys and do the demands of Skidmore. I mean, we never left there until midnight when there was a project going. That was just automatic. You were just there. I'm Margaret McCurry. I'm a partner in Tigerman McCurry Architects.
在此之前，我在SOM建筑事务所工作了11年。娜塔莉在我任职期间也在那里。我和她合作过一个项目，圣乔治山谷银行。嗯，她是SOM传统的一部分。我在那里度过的11年就像是在读研究生一样。我学到了比例、细节以及那些我认为
Before that, I was at Skidmore, Owings and Merrill for 11 years. And Natalie was there during the time I was. I worked on one project with her, the St. Joe Valley Bank. Well, she was part of the SOM tradition. The 11 years I spent there was like being in graduate school, really. I learned proportion and detailing and things that were,
在创造和谐美妙的空间方面至关重要的东西。这也是她遗产的一部分，她属于那一类人。我的城市，芝加哥。所以我们经常为了快乐和通勤去公园，而今晚我从未见过如此多的丑陋、愚蠢和残暴。我在芝加哥市中心格兰公园的这个清晨看到了一些示威活动，
I think, important in creating spaces that are harmonious and beautiful. And that was part of her legacy too, that she was of that ilk. My city, Chicago. So we go to the park often for a joy and commuting, and tonight I've never saw as much ugliness in the stupidity and brutality. I've been some demonstrations this early hour in downtown Chicago's Grant Park to
刚才听说已经使用了催泪瓦斯。我们经历过正常的生活。60年代是美国历史上一个颇具决定性的时刻。那是一个动荡的时代。民权斗争占据了前台。女性的生活发出了自己的声音。越南战争、暗杀、学生革命。1968年民主党全国代表大会在那里举行以及随后的芝加哥七君子审判时，你一定在芝加哥。现状受到了来自各个方面的攻击。而且这也波及到了我的孩子。以什么方式？
hurt a moment ago that tear gas has been used. We have been through normal life. The 60s was quite a defining moment in American history. It was a time of turmoil. The civil right struggle was at the fore. Women's lived, found its voice. Vietnam, assassinations, student revolves. You must have been in Chicago in 1968 when the Democratic Convention was there and then the Chicago Seven Trials that followed. The status quo was under attack from every court. And it was under attack with my children too. In what way?
我不知道。在民权运动的那天，有一张戴利走在街上的照片，而我的孩子尾随其后。当时到底发生了什么？那是你没有答案的问题。我没有答案。60年代的芝加哥只是一个奇怪而艰难的时期。我会去公园，我没有参与其中任何事情，但我一直在观察这一切。就娜塔莉而言，她显然意识到了这一点，但我们从未谈论过
I don't know. That day of the Civil Rights Movement, there was a picture of daily walking down the street, and my kid's trailing him. What was going down down? That was a question you didn't have an answer for. I didn't have an answer for. Chicago in the 60s was just the strange and difficult time. I would go out in the park, and I wasn't involved in any of it, but I was observing all of it. And as far as Nally is concerned, she was obviously aware of this, but we never talked about
它。伴随着60年代的所有这些动荡，女性主义运动的发展，而你在提升女性建筑师地位方面发挥了非常显眼的作用。没错。娜塔莉离开纽约去了芝加哥。第二波女权主义运动开始兴起，她顺理成章地退居到某种局外行动主义的行列中。来结识其他女性建筑师，关于930联合会，1974年1月12日，格特鲁德·伦普·科维斯办公室，密歇根北路664号，芝加哥，欢迎所有人。格特鲁德，即森达·波尔斯卡德，邀请了所有女性建筑师
it. With all of this turmoil going on in the 60s, in the women's movement, and you were very much apparent in promoting the status of women architects. That's right. Natalie leaves New York and goes to Chicago. Second wave feminism starts to happen, and she backs into a kind of sideline of activism. Come and meet other female architects regarding coalition 930 AM January 12th 1974, Office of Gertrude Lump Curvis 664 North Michigan Chicago, all invited. Gertrude Senada Polskhard, it invited all women architects
到她的办公室开会。那基本上就是一个房间。也许有15乘15英尺大。我是卡罗尔·罗斯·巴尼。我是芝加哥的一名建筑师，娜塔莉·德布瓦是我的朋友和导师。我的整个职业生涯都在芝加哥执业。1971年我从乌尔巴纳的伊利诺伊大学毕业后就来到了这里。
to a meeting at her office. It was basically a room. Maybe it was 15 by 15. I'm Carol Ross Barney. I'm an architect in Chicago, Natalie DeBloy was my friend and my mentor. I've been practicing in Chicago my entire career. I came here after I graduated from the University of Illinois in Urbana in 1971.
我开始为霍利伍德和鲁特工作。娜塔莉和格特鲁德·克比斯决定在芝加哥把女性召集到一起时，我正在那里。那是CWA（芝加哥女建筑师协会）的成立。我是在那次第一次会议上认识她的。我已经在霍利伍德工作了一段时间。没有其他女性，所以我就去了。你知道的，我真的很好奇。这次会议上大概有不到二十名，也许十多名女性。她走进房间时，我其实对娜塔莉一无所知。
I started working for Hollywood and Root. I was there when Natalie and Gertrude Kerbis decided to call women together in Chicago. That was the formation of CWA Chicago women in architecture. I first met her at that first meeting. I had been working at Hollywood for a while. There were no other women, so I went. I was, you know, really curious. There were probably less than two dozen, maybe a dozen women at this meeting. I actually knew nothing about Natalie when she walked into the room.
她和一小群人一起走了进来。同行的人绝对不超过两三个。而且她令人印象深刻。她一直都是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。非常英气。带有一点神秘感。直到所有这些建筑师聚在一起开始分享各自的故事，她才意识到拥有一个女性的社会和政治网络是多么重要。这几乎就像是——我不想表现得太戏剧化——但感觉就像大坝决堤了，她开始意识到，哇，我们曾经走过的路真是太难了，哇，那些事确实发生在我身上过。当时存在这样一个问题：在这里，我们在这些工作中孤立无援。
She walked in with a small group. It couldn't have been more than two or three women. And she was impressive. She was very impressive person, always. Very handsome. Kind of mysterious. She didn't realize how important it was to have a social and political network of women until all of these architects got together and just started sharing their stories. It was almost as if I don't want to be too dramatic but it was like almost the dam broke and she started to realize wow it was really tough what we did and wow that really happened to me. There was a question about, here we are, all alone in these jobs.
我们该去向何方？所以这对我来说真是一个大开眼界的时刻。我们发出了行动呼吁。目标是创造平等，让女性的工作为人所知。我们在那次讨论的基础上成立了一个组织。我们决定要让女性建筑师的作品更多地为人所知，于是我们开始筹备一个展览。它基本上揭示了当时芝加哥女性在做的事情。
Where do we go? And so it was a real eye-opener for me. We had a call to action. And it was to create equality and make women's work better known. And we started an organization out of that discussion. And we decided that we wanted to make the work of women architects better known, so we started planning and exhibit. And it basically uncovered what Chicago women were doing then.
建筑展在当时非常受欢迎，所以我们觉得自己在做一件伟大的事情。此时，苏珊娜·托利也完成了她的书《美国建筑中的女性》，而娜塔莉是该出版物中的核心人物。所以是的，我是说，她和格特鲁德·克比斯，她们是展出内容、展览呈现以及我们在精神上所做之事的领军人物。嗯，我见过很多非正式的文件，呼吁人们开会，通常角落里会用铅笔写着：在娜塔莉家吃晚饭。是的，我记得卡罗尔·巴尼25岁，而我50岁。我记得她爬上楼梯的样子，她总是来开会，我们当中有一群人关系非常非常近。
Architecture shows were really popular then, and so we thought we were doing a great service. At this point, Susanna Torrey also had completed her book Women in American Architecture, and Natalie was a major figure in that publication. So yes, I mean, she and Gertrude Kerbis, they were the leaders of both what was shown and what was exhibited, and spiritually what we were doing. Well, I have seen a lot of informal papers calling people to meetings and often it would be penciled up in the corner, supper at Natalie's. Yeah, I remember Carol Barning was 25 and I was 50. I remember her climbing up the stairs and she always come to the meetings and there were a group of us that were very, very close.
这非常有意义。到这个时候，我们已经是很好的朋友了。当她从SOM辞职时，不幸的是，我认为在我们两人都离开后，她看到其他一些合伙人转向了后现代主义。这绝不是她所欣赏的风格。时代在变，命运流转，沉浮不定，如果那个世界变了，那你就会抽身离开，跳进另一个世界。你知道的，她是个实用主义者。德克萨斯大学，我去了那里开始教书。我教了13年，从80年到93年。
And it was very meaningful. We were really good friends at this point. When she quit, it's good more. Unfortunately, I think after both of us left, she saw some of the other partners moving into postmodernism. And that would not have been her thing at all. Tides change in fortunes and the pendulum swings, and if that world changes, then you hop
我是约翰·纽曼。我是一名建筑师。我去了德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校，娜塔莉曾是我的教授。那是在1983年。德克萨斯大学拥有这座令人惊叹的保罗·克雷设计建筑大楼。我上娜塔莉的设计课时，建筑大楼正在翻新。所以我们在一个废弃的小学里。
off and hop into another one. You know, she was a pragmatist. The University of Texas, I went down there and started teaching. I taught for 13 years, 80 to 93. My name is John Newman. I'm an architect. I went to the University of Texas at Austin, and I had Natalie as a professor there. That was in 1983. The University of Texas has this amazing Paul Kray design architecture building. At the time that I took studio from Natalie, the architecture building was under renovation. So we were in an abandoned elementary school.
这是一栋木结构建筑，有14英尺高的天花板，还有大约10英寸高的厕所。你可以在地板上喷漆，没人会在意，反正明年无论如何都要拆掉。工作室很凌乱，没有什么东西是需要小心翼翼供起来的，那是一个非常棒的工作坊环境。你可以随便瞎折腾、做出东西、拆掉它们，然后重新组装。她会跟你谈论非常技术性的问题，比如那样做不符合规范，或者那样不符合项目要求，或者那样不符合项目要求，或者那样不符合分区规定。有很多这样的内容，她会鼓励你去挑战规范。
Woodframe building with 14 foot ceilings and toilets that were about 10 inches tall. You could spray paint on the floor and nobody cared because they were gonna tear it down next year anyway. The studio was messy, nothing was precious, and it was a really great workshop environment. You could just fuss around and make stuff and tear stuff up and put it back together. She would talk to you about really technical issues about how that doesn't meet the code or that doesn't meet the program or that doesn't meet the program or that doesn't meet the zoning. There was a lot of that and she would encourage you to challenge the code.
娜塔莉可以说是置身于纽约市分区和建筑规范战后现代化改造的开端。她谈到自己下班后骑着自行车绕着纽约市转，去参加规范委员会的会议，会在建筑规范上工作几个小时，然后去和马塞尔·布鲁尔喝一杯。50、60年代活跃的纽约建筑师会在晚上9点聚集在布拉扎里餐厅，她会顺道拜访，那里聚集了所有人，
Natalie was sort of there at the beginning of the post-war modernizations of New York City zoning and building codes. She talked about riding her bike around New York City after work going up to the code committee meetings and she would go work on building code for a couple of hours and then she would meet Marcel Breuer for drinks. The active New York architects from the 50s and 60s would be at Brazari at nine o'clock in the evening and she would drop in and it would be all these people
这就是她一天结束时与之交往的圈子。在我读硕士的最后一年，我在德克萨斯大学上了娜塔莉·杜布瓦的高层建筑设计课。当我在读这个项目时，那是我每年都想去参观的设计课，因为实在是太壮观了。塑造我们城市生活的垂直世界的想法对我来说太迷人了。我是彼得·迪克森。我是Profeit品牌创新公司的资深合伙人。我是这家公司的首席创意官，我很幸运能在1986年在德克萨斯大学上过娜塔莉的高层建筑设计课，成为她的学生。
and that's just who she hung out with at the end of the day. My last year of my master's program, I took Natalie Du Bois, tall building studio at UT. As I was coming through the program, that was the studio I wanted to go see every year because it was spectacular. The idea of shaping the vertical world of our urban life was just fascinating to me. I'm Peter Dixon. I'm a senior partner at Profit of Branding Innovation Farm. I'm the Spirms Chief Creative Officer and I had the good fortune of being Natalie Student at the
娜塔莉随时乐意与人探讨实践和工作。事实上，她再次在帮我联系我在纽约市的第一份实习方面发挥了关键作用，后来我搬到了SOM，也就是娜塔莉声名鹊起的地方，并成为了在SOM工作的这批德克萨斯大学建筑师群体的一部分。
University of Texas in 1986 in her Tall-Builded in Studio. Natalie was always available for a conversation about practice and working. She actually was, again, instrumental in getting me connected to my first internship in New York City, and then moved to SOM where Natalie had made her fame and fortune and became part of this UT group of architects working at SOM.
很多时候，她是房间里唯一的女性，我认为这磨练了她的坚韧。她必须赢得人们的尊重，我认为这种尊重贯穿了她余下的职业生涯。你知道她带进课堂的尊重，每个人对她知识的敬意都是显而易见的。你看她，她在体型上很娇小，但她精力充沛、坚韧不拔。她非常直率。她从不试图粉饰太平，以一种好的方式进行批判，就像任何合格的批评家那样，进行有益的批判。但在这一切之下，有着一颗充满温情的心。
She was the only woman in the room many times and I think it toughened her up. She had to earn her respect and I think it carried through the rest of her time. You know the respect that she brought into the classroom, the respect that everyone had for her knowledge was just evident. You know to see her she, she was slight physically, but she was wierry. And she was tough. She was very direct. And she didn't try to sugarcoat it, judgmental in a good way, as any critic should be, usefully judgmental. But there was heart below it all.
事实上，她从事着如此重要、强大、具有标志性的工作，却总是被视为“帮戈登拎包的女人”，这一定很艰难。我不认为她对此怀有怨恨。我认为她只是有这样一种顺从的态度。事情就是这样。不，我无法想象那种感觉是怎样的，但我确实认为，建筑历史上有娜塔莉这样的人这一事实，带来了一种通过百事可乐大楼及其精致细节得以体现的敏感度，我认为这种类型的工作在建筑学和建筑史中占有一席之地，如果没有她，这个地位将会黯然失色。她谈到了她的学生和研讨会。
The fact that she was doing such important, powerful, iconic work and always be seen as the woman carrying Gordon's bag, so to speak, must have been tough. I don't think she has resentment about that. I think she just had this idea of resignation. That's the way it was. No, I can't imagine how that is, but I do think the fact that there are people like Natalie in the canon of architecture I think there's a sensitivity that came through we think about the Pepsi Cola building and its refinement and Detail I think about that kind of work has a place in architecture and in the canon that would be less if she had not been around She talked about her students in Sesame.
在SOM，我负责多年来（在我任职的大部分时间里）所有设计师的招聘工作。许多德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校的孩子们来这里找工作，他们都很棒。我很喜欢这些孩子，他们都曾受教于娜塔莉。她很严厉，但做事一丝不苟。她要求严格，人们都爱她。她被奉若神明。随着年龄的增长，她变得健谈了一点。她会谈论她的研讨会、那里的课程，
At Skidmore, I was in charge of doing all the hiring of the designers for a number of years, most of the time that I was there. And a lot of UT Austin kids came through looking for jobs, and they were great. I loved these kids, and they'd all been taught by Natalie. She was tough, but she was thorough. She was demanding, and people loved her. She was idolized. As she got older, she got a little more communicative. And she would talk about her seminar, her classes there,
以及她深爱的学生们。当SOM的事情开始分崩离析时发生在她身上的那些事。她从未被升为合伙人。她没有怀恨重重。她只是放下过去，重新开始生活。结果证明这对她来说是一段不可思议的经历。关于娜塔莉·德布瓦的生活与时代，更多内容，广告之后见。这里再次是由娜塔莉·德布瓦带来的《新角度之声》栏目“说出真相”。要成为娜塔莉的朋友，你的脸皮不能太薄。她非常直言不讳。你必须随时准备好听到这样的评论：“你知道，我觉得你应该这样做”或者“这不够好”之类的话。但我发现她作为一个朋友非常忠诚，我知道我们当中有一群人也是这么觉得的。
and her students, who she loved. The things that happened to her when the Skidmore thing kind of fell apart. She was never made a partner. She didn't hold a grudge. She just went down and started her life over again. And it turned out to be an incredible experience for her. More on the life and times of Natalie Deploy, after this. Here again is Natalie Deploy to tell the truth from New Angle Voice. To be Natalie's friend, you could not have a thin skin. She was very blunt. You had to be ready for comments that were like, you know, I think you should do this or this
她认为指导女性和芝加哥女建筑师协会是她做过的最重要的事之一。这些对她来说始终很重要。我不知道她为什么会成为我的朋友，为什么她选中了我，但我很高兴她这么做了。这段友谊真的非常重要。我的孩子们讨厌她，因为她也会对他们指手画脚。
isn't that good or whatever. But I found her quite devoted as a friend and I know there was a group of us who did. She thought mentoring women and Chicago women and architecture were among the most important things she did. They were always important to her. I don't know why she became my friend why she picked me, but I'm glad she did. It was really an important friendship. My kids hated her because she'd tell them what to do too.
她过去常来家里，然后她也会告诉他们该做什么。她来到家里，然后她就会对他们发号施令。有一次我去奥黑尔机场接她，她穿着一条黑裤子和一件雨衣。我对此记忆犹新，因为我问：“你的行李呢？”她拉开雨衣，内袋里插着一把牙刷。她就在这里，所以，是的，她会跟我们住在一起，然后她就会在家里当家作主。关于娜塔莉的一切都相当令人惊奇。她非常古怪。我的意思是，就是古怪，那种奇妙的古怪。
She used to come into the house and they, she'd tell them what to do too. She's coming to the house and they she'd tell them what to do and one time I picked her up at O'Hare and she's wearing a pair of black pants and a raincoat. I remember this distinctly because I said where's your luggage and she opened up the raincoat and she had a tooth brush in the inside pocket. She's in here and so yeah so she'd stay with us and then she would rule the roost. Everything about Natalie was quite surprising. She was very odd. I mean, just odd, just wonderfully odd.
她以前来家里的时候，也会对他们指手画脚。她来到家里，然后她会对他们指手画脚，有一次我在奥黑尔机场接她，她穿着一条黑裤子和一件雨衣。我清楚地记得这件事，因为我问她的行李在哪里，她打开雨衣，内袋里插着一把牙刷。她在这里，所以是的，她会和我们住在一起，然后她就会当家作主。娜塔莉的一切都相当令人惊讶。她非常古怪。我的意思是，就是古怪，那种奇妙的古怪。
But you know, accomplish what she did. I think you would have to be that extraordinary. How do you describe people who are just so different? Her attitude, what she would tolerate, what she wouldn't tolerate, what she saw. She had great eyes. You know, I take her out to a job site. I was working on it at some point. She'd see stuff about my work that I hadn't seen. And it's just really great. I remember the last time I saw it was here in New York City. Very, very cold day. She had her will and tights on and her dress and
但你知道，她取得了这样的成就。我想你必须得是那样非凡的人。你该如何形容那些如此与众不同的人呢？她的态度，她所能容忍的，她所不能容忍的，她所看到的。她有着极好的眼光。你知道，我曾带她去过一个工地。我当时正在那里工作。她能看出我工作中连我自己都没注意到的问题。这真的是太棒了。我记得最后一次见她是在纽约市。非常非常冷的一天。她穿着羊毛裤、裙子和
her beautiful tweed coat. And we walked around and looked at buildings in the cold afternoon, stopped in for a glass of wine every once in a while, and then went on to look at some more buildings. After her sister died and her house was sold and she wasn't teaching anymore, she moved back to Chicago. She took the Great Books course at the University of Chicago. She continued to take French courses. She called the Chicago Public Library her club. But she'd be all over the city. I think that's why she came back here.
她那件美丽的花呢大衣。我们在寒冷的下午四处走动，欣赏着一栋栋建筑，每隔一段时间就停下来喝上一杯葡萄酒，然后继续看更多的建筑。她的姐姐去世后，房子卖了，她也不再教书了，于是她搬回了芝加哥。她在芝加哥大学修读了“伟大著作”课程。她继续上法语课。她把芝加哥公共图书馆称为她的俱乐部。但她的足迹遍布整个城市。我想这就是她回来的原因。
It's because there was so much that interested her and that was accessible for her. She slowed down a bit and and eventually she bought a different apartment in the Mies-Vendero building in Hyde Park, and that's where she was until she died. She's still super active, but her health started to get a little bit diceier. She fell when Winter and Broker hit. That slowed her down somewhat, but she did recover.
因为这里有太多让她感兴趣、且对她来说触手可及的东西。她稍微慢了下来，最终在海德公园的密斯·凡德罗大楼里买下了另一套公寓，她就一直住在那里直到去世。她依然超级活跃，但她的健康状况开始变得有点不太稳定。冬天和布罗克袭击时她摔倒了。这让她稍微放慢了脚步，但她确实康复了。
I mean, she eventually was running around again. No one went to her and broke her hip. That slowed her down somewhat, but she did recover. I mean, she eventually was running around again. She was 90 already, and she received a diagnosis. This time it was a uterine cancer. She took some chemo, and she took some therapies, but then she decided it just wasn't worth it. And so Patrick, her son, moved into her apartment and cared for her. And that's where she died, July 2013. It wasn't unexpected, but I wasn't ready for it. There was a story once she was going around giving speeches. After the speech, a student came up to her
我的意思是，她最终又开始四处奔波了。没有人去找她还摔断了髋骨。这让她稍微放慢了脚步，但她确实康复了。我的意思是，她最终又开始四处奔波了。她当时已经90岁了，并被确诊了。这一次是子宫癌。她接受了一些化疗和治疗，但随后她觉得这根本不值得。于是她的儿子帕特里克搬进了她的公寓照顾她。她就在那里去世了，2013年7月。这并非意料之外，但我还没做好心理准备。曾经有个故事讲到她到处去演讲。演讲结束后，一个学生走到她面前
and said, I'm from Chicago. And when I was a high school student, Chicago, I was taking the bus one day, and we were going across the Chicago River, and this kid came up to me and told me that his mother designed that building. And this woman said, yeah, and that's when I decided, I wanted to be an architect, that a woman could be an architect. And I remember that incident.
说：“我是芝加哥人。当我还是芝加哥的高中生时，有一天我坐着公交车，我们正要穿过芝加哥河，这个孩子走过来对我说，他的母亲设计了那栋建筑。”这个女人说：“是的，就是在那时我决定，我想成为一名建筑师，女性也可以成为建筑师。”我还记得那个事件。
I saw this girl on the boss and just started chatting to her. And as we went by the equitable building, I said, oh yeah, by the way, my mother designed that building. That'd take great pride. And I would always talk about, actually, both my parents, it's like, Natalie had two sides, well not two sides, you know, million sides. Along with the bad inspiration isn't exactly the word but just awe at her accomplishment. I've never lost that. I'm always amazed that I knew these people or that
我看到这个女孩在公交车上，就跟她聊了起来。当我们路过公平大厦时，我说：“哦，顺便说一句，我母亲设计了那栋建筑。”那会让人感到无比自豪。我总是会谈论，实际上是我的父母双方，就好像娜塔莉有两面，好吧不只是两面，你知道，有数百万面。除了不尽的灵感——这词或许不太准确，但可以说是对她成就的敬畏。我从未失去过这种感觉。我总是惊讶于我认识这些人，或者
somehow I came from them. I now open the public hearing on this application. In early 2018, JPMorgan announced they would take advantage of the East Midtown Resoning project passed in 2017 by rebuilding their headquarters at 270 Park Avenue. 270 Park, formerly the Union Carbide Building, which of course had been occupied by JPMorgan Chase. It's always fascinating to watch buildings being demolished, but in that case, it was just sort of horrifying, again, for complex reasons.
不知怎的我是从他们之中走出来的。我现在宣布开始对这项申请进行公开听证。2018年初，摩根大通宣布他们将利用2017年通过的“中城东区再区划”项目，重建他们位于公园大道270号的总部。公园大道270号，前身为联合碳化物大楼，当然曾被摩根大通占用。看着建筑物被拆除总是令人着迷，但在那种情况下，由于种种复杂的原因，它简直有点令人毛骨悚然。
There were many debates about the importance of its preservation because it was designed by Natalie DeBloy. To me, the most egregious dimension of its demolition was that it was unnecessary. And in 2020, as we like to say, the Green's building is the one that's standing. The idea of taking down a building of that scale, only to replace it with something that is even bigger,
关于保留它的重要性有许多争论，因为它是由娜塔莉·德布瓦设计的。对我来说，它被拆除最令人发指的一点在于，这是完全不必要的。到了2020年，正如我们喜欢说的那样，格林大楼才是那座依然挺立的大楼。拆除如此规模建筑的想法，却只是用一个更大的建筑来取代它，
it just, it seems, grotesque. You're gonna put a 52-story skyscraper into a dumpster. Now that's not sustainable. It is the largest on-purpose demolition of any building in the world. We can't do that anymore. My name is Liz Whitehakes and I'm the executive director of Doca Momo, US. At the end of the Bloomberg administration, he gave what we all said was a gift to the developers, which was to rezone East Midtown.
这简直太荒谬了。你要把一座52层的摩天大楼扔进垃圾箱。这可一点都不环保。这是世界上对任何建筑物进行的规模最大的蓄意拆除。我们不能再这样做了。我叫莉兹·怀特海克斯，我是Doca Momo美国分部的执行董事。在布隆伯格政府执政末期，他送出了一件我们大家都说是给开发商的礼物，那就是对中城东区进行重新区划。
Developers could transfer air rights, not just to adjacent properties, but throughout the district and build taller buildings. When we found out that Chase wanted to tear down a 52 story skyscraper, Jokomomo really stepped into action. The Landmarks Preservation Commission said that it was eligible to be a landmark. We went to landmarks and said, okay, now is the time. Like you've said, this is significant. Let's landmark this building and protect it. And the response we received was they did not believe that there was enough support. And I think one of the other responses from landmarks that really irked preservationists was that landmarks had already designated a number of buildings by SOM on Park Avenue. And that
开发商可以将空气权转让给不只是相邻的物业，而是整个地区的物业，从而建造更高的楼宇。当我们发现大通银行想要拆除一座52层的摩天大楼时，Jokomomo真正采取了行动。地标保护委员会表示，它符合成为地标的资格。我们去找地标委员会说：“好吧，现在是时候了。正如你们所说，这具有重要意义。让我们把这座建筑定为地标并保护它吧。”我们得到的回复是，他们认为支持力度不够。我想地标委员会的另一个回应让保护主义者真的感到恼火，那就是地标委员会已经在公园大道上指定了许多由SOM设计的建筑，并且
Natalie had another building, the Pepsi Cola building on Park Avenue, and that was already designated. So what? We don't need another building designed by Gordon Bunchev and Natalie DeBloy. You know, everyone talks about Natalie being a designer of skyscrapers. I mean, Pepsi Cola is wonderful. It's a jewel box. It's 10 stories. We're talking about a 52 story skyscraper.
娜塔莉还有另一座建筑，位于公园大道上的百事可乐大楼，那已经是一个指定地标了。那又怎样？我们不需要另一座由戈登·邦沙夫特和娜塔莉·德布瓦设计的建筑。你知道，每个人都谈论娜塔莉是摩天大楼的设计师。我的意思是，百事可乐大楼很棒。它就像一个珠宝盒。它有10层高。而我们谈论的是一座52层的摩天大楼。
And the suggestion from landmarks that we need to preserve buildings like an architectural penning zoo is just ridiculous. And if there was one building to tell people a story of Nanli in the art city and her work with SOM, I really think it was 270 Park Avenue. My name is Troulee Murphy. I'm a principal at Skidmore Owings in Merrill and I was part of a group of women who in 2008 started the SOM Women's Initiative. I started at SOM in 2008, and I think that time was interesting because there had been women partners in the past at the firm.
地标委员会建议我们需要保护像建筑动物园珍品这样的建筑，这简直太荒谬了。如果有一座建筑能向人们讲述娜塔莉在艺术之城的故事以及她与SOM的工作，我真的认为那就是公园大道270号。我叫特鲁利·墨菲。我是斯金默·奥因斯与梅里尔建筑事务所（SOM）的合伙人，我曾是一群女性中的一员，我们在2008年发起了“SOM女性倡议”。我于2008年加入SOM，我认为那个时期很有趣，因为该事务所过去曾有过女性合伙人。
It was a time when there were no women partners. That was a little shocking to me, I think. And together with a number of colleagues who were probably in the same level of seniority, we were all young in our careers, we're complaining at a bar about how, you know, we thought that there was a gender imbalance in the leadership, and we decided to revive a group that actually had been led by one of the notable women partners, Marilyn Taylor, who had left the firm to be the dean of the University of Pennsylvania. And it really kind of grew out of covetching to saying, what can we do for ourselves, what can we do for the office to try to make inroads into this kind of glaring situation? situation. The idea that there had been women who were exceptional here in our own
那是一个没有女性合伙人的时期。这对我来说多少有点令人震惊。与许多可能处于相同资历水平的同事一起——我们当时在职业生涯中都很年轻，我们在酒吧里抱怨说，你知道，我们认为领导层中存在性别失衡，我们决定复兴一个实际上曾由一位杰出的女性合伙人领导的组织，那就是玛丽莲·泰勒，她当时离开事务所去担任宾夕法尼亚大学的院长。这真的有点从发牢骚演变成思考：我们能为自己做些什么，我们能为办公室做些什么，以试图打入这种显而易见的局面？这种局面。这里曾有杰出的女性，就在我们自己的
microcosm of the history of modern architecture was certainly something that was notable, remarkable, and I think a point of inspiration. I think about our workplace. Ten years ago it seemed like a great idea to give women with young children laptops because they might have to go home and they might need to work later. And they shouldn't be penalized for that. Now we're in a place where currently we come to the office two days a week and in the future we think we're going to be here three days a week. So so much flexibility, especially for people who might have more complex home situations,
现代建筑史的微观世界里，这无疑是引人注目、非凡的，我认为也是一个灵感的来源。我想到了我们的工作场所。十年前，给有年幼孩子的女性配备笔记本电脑似乎是个绝妙的主意，因为她们可能不得不回家，可能还需要晚些时候工作。她们不应该因此受到惩罚。现在我们的情况是，目前我们每周去办公室两天，将来我们觉得可能会每周去三天。因此，提供了如此多的 flexibility（灵活性），特别是对于那些可能有更复杂的家庭状况的人来说，
than I could have ever dreamt of just a mere decade ago. To me, obviously her professional life and her personal life were separate. And I know what it's like to work a full-time job. It's really hard to come home from that and relate to your children in a deep and meaningful way. I believe she was aware of the effect our lives had on us, though she wouldn't let it affect her professional life. I think she felt she'd bush things that worked out differently.
这比我仅仅在十年前所能梦想的还要多。对我来说，很显然她的职业生活和个人生活是分开的。我知道全职工作是什么感觉。下班回家后还要以一种深刻而有意义的方式与孩子们建立联系，这真的很不容易。我相信她意识到了生活对我们的影响，尽管她不会让这种影响波及她的职业生活。我想她觉得有些事情本可以有不同的结果。
I do, but you know, things don't always work out the way you want them to. When I say she was on feeling, I mean we didn't talk about feelings and stuff like that, but I certainly believe she had them and just didn't know how to express them as well as some people do or as some people want to. She was very persistent, but I think her persistence was admirable. She is what I call a real architect.
我确实这么认为，但你知道，事情并不总是如你所愿。当我说她没有感情时，我是指我们不谈论感情之类的事情，但我绝对相信她有感情，只是不知道如何像某些人那样，或者像某些人想要的那样好地表达出来。她非常坚持不懈，但我认为她的坚持是令人钦佩的。她是我所说的一个真正的建筑师。
Not an architect that makes cool forms on the computer. Not an architect that sees everything through the lens of theory. But an architect who wants to build, wants to build well and wants to learn and build more and build better and to do everything. The thing that makes me happiest is to see that she's now being recognized for her real role. Young people are learning about her in a very different way. We didn't even learn about her, to be honest. I mean I learned about her because I knew some people at Skidmore who really admired her and they told me about her. I'm just so glad that she now is someone to look up to for men and
不是那种在电脑上做出炫酷形态的建筑师。不是那种通过理论视角看待一切的建筑师。而是一位渴望建造、渴望建好、渴望学习并建造更多、建造得更好并把一切都做好的建筑师。最让我开心的是看到她现在因其真正的角色而受到认可。年轻人正以一种非常不同的方式了解她。老实说，我们甚至都没有学过她。我的意思是，我了解她是因为我认识一些斯金默事务所里非常崇拜她的人，他们向我讲述了她。我太高兴了，她现在成为了男性和
women and that her true accomplishments are being known and I think that's only going to grow. That is the thing I'm happiest about. I mean, having lost her, which was the real gift, but this I think is a gift to all of us. Modernism. She obviously played a big role in creating it. You know, you can talk about Mies, you can talk about Bauhaus, and she obviously played a very big role in disseminating it and making it accessible to everybody. When I see pictures of the lever house or Connecticut General, she didn't set out to build something beautiful. She set out to build something that worked.
女性都可以仰望的人，她真正的成就会被世人所知，而且我认为这种影响力只会越来越大。这就是最让我高兴的事情。我的意思是，失去了她，这是一份真正的礼物，但这我认为是我们所有人的礼物。现代主义。她显然在创造现代主义的过程中发挥了巨大作用。你知道，你可以谈论密斯，你可以谈论包豪斯，而她显然在传播现代主义并使其为所有人所接受方面发挥了非常重要的作用。当我看到利弗大厦或康涅狄格通用人寿保险公司的照片时，她并不是为了建造某种美丽的东西而出发的。她是怀着建造实用之物的目标出发的。
And because of her aesthetic qualities, she made something beautiful. To me, that was the great essence of Natalie. Her practicality somehow meshed with some aesthetic that was amazing. Special thanks to Gabriel Esperdie, Audrey Matlock, Carol Kinsky, Carol Ross Barney, Margaret McCurray, Peter Dixon, John Newman, Liz Whiteakus, Julia Murphy, and Robert DeBloy. The archival audio of Natalie DeBloy, interviewed by Betty Blum, is from the Art Institute of Chicago, Chicago Architects' oral history project. Thank you to Nathaniel Parks,
并且由于她对美学的追求，她造就了美丽的事物。对我来说，这就是娜塔莉的精髓所在。她的务实精神不知何故与某种惊人的美学完美融合。特别感谢加布里埃尔·埃斯佩尔迪、奥黛丽·马特洛克、卡罗尔·金斯基、卡罗尔·罗斯·巴尼、玛格丽特·麦克雷、彼得·迪克森、约翰·纽曼、莉兹·怀特海克斯、茱莉亚·墨菲和罗伯特·德布瓦。娜塔莉·德布瓦的档案馆音频由贝蒂·布拉姆采访，取自芝加哥艺术博物馆的芝加哥建筑师口述历史项目。感谢内撒尼尔·帕克斯，
Director of the Art Institute of Chicago Archives, for your help with this recording. This podcast is produced by Brandi Howell with editorial advising from Alexandra Lang. Special thanks to Matt Alvarez, and Iowa Public Radio for their production assistance. New Angle Voice is brought to you by the Beverly Willis Architecture Foundation with support from Miller Nol and SOM.
芝加哥艺术博物馆档案馆馆长，感谢您对本期录音的帮助。本期播客由布兰迪·豪威尔制作，亚历山德拉·朗提供编辑顾问。特别感谢马特·阿尔瓦雷斯和爱荷华公共广播电台提供的制作协助。新视角之声（New Angle Voice）由贝弗利威利斯建筑基金会为您呈现，并得到了米勒诺尔和SOM的支持。
If you missed our first episode, finding Julian Morgan, be sure to give a listen wherever you find your podcasts. And if you like this episode, please leave a review and share with a friend. We will be back in March with more exciting episodes, so stay tuned for more. Until then, I'm your host, Cynthia Crackauer. Thank you for listening. Cynthia Crackauer. Thank you for listening. Joe Rosenberg, Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson, Washington, Don, Jason Dillion, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars.
如果你错过了我们的第一集《寻找朱利安·摩根》，无论你在哪里收听播客，请务必去听一听。如果你喜欢这一集，请留下评论并与朋友分享。我们将在三月带着更多精彩的节目回归，请敬请期待。在此之前，我是主持人辛西娅·克拉克劳。谢谢收听。辛西娅·克拉克劳。谢谢收听。乔·罗森伯格、克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、华盛顿·唐、杰森·狄龙、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马斯。
We are part of the Stitcher and Series XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, and beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org.
我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼内，位于美丽且高档的奥克兰上城，加利福尼亚州。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars 或@节目 @99PI org。
We're on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Stitcher! Serious exam. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜欢其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。Stitcher！SiriusXM。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。